vous faites pour votre colette dans une
chambrette alain papot vous avez loukoum
envie quand ma vie le cabinet de
toilette trois ans avec vous ah oui un
paddock 30 dans l'évier à la cuisine je
fais montage dans l'entrée oui à lavabo
la machine dans ma chambre d'hôtel des
vidéos très vite votre aise dans la
chambre vous allez bientôt les boutons
croix le genre de gars je constate une
chose qui a beaucoup de logements qui ne
possèdent pas de salle de bains et pour
ma part personnelle beaucoup de gens
désiraient mais la place n'est pas
suffisante je vais aux douces l'estonie
oui mais tous les jours au lavabo à
découvrir dans la cuisine est ce que
vous aimeriez voir une salle de bain
bien sûr pensez vous que ce soit un luxe
non je pense pas non une salle de bain
n'est pas un luxe est cependant en
france pour 46 millions 200 mille
habitants soit 14 millions 500 mille
logements
45 % des logements ne possède pas d'eau
70% de la population rurale soit près de
15 millions d'habitants ne dispose pas
du tout à l'égout dans paris même dans
ce quartier où nous nous promenons
actuellement dans ce vieux quartier
royal du marais dont la densité de
population atteint 582 habitants à
l'hectare
75% des maisons ont été construites
avant 1875 10 % des logements n'ont pas
l'électricité 30 % n'ont pas l'eau
courante
74 % n'ont aucune commodité individuel à
paris va pour cent seulement des
logements possède une salle de bains ou
un cabinet de toilette et 15 % en
province c'est pas un luxe réellement
mais c'est une nécessité of du tout du
tout du tout du tout c'est une nécessité
non certainement pas bon du tout au
contraire c'est un besoin c'est une
nécessité même tout le monde devrait en
avoir une non c'est une nécessité ben
c'est indispensable
j'ai des enfants alors pas du tout pas
du tout site mais je trouve en 1968
nécessité ce n'est pas du tout un luxe
oh non pas du tout et le contraire bonne
rasade dans certaines familles c'est une
nécessité pourquoi dans certaines
familles la cible et plus par une
famille qui a plusieurs enfants
[Musique]
pour une seule personne c'est un luxe
pour une seule personne oui mais pour
plusieurs ce qui nécessitait de
nécessité absolue non c'est pas un hoax
une nécessité parce que les gens ont
besoin de se laver j'estime pour ma part
personnelle sur la propreté et beaucoup
de choses mais la salle de 20 at elle
une autre fonction dans la vie
quotidienne c'est ce que nous avons
demandé à monsieur et bahreïn secrétaire
général de l'union des syndicats des
fabricants du matériel de seconde terre
certainement la salle de bain doit avoir
dans la vie quotidienne
une fonction qui dépasse très largement
la simple satisfaction des règles
d'hygiène elle doit être en plus et
beaucoup plus le lieu où l'homme moderne
fatigué de ces journées très chargées
doit pouvoir trouver le repos la détente
nécessaire à son équilibre physique cet
aspect de la salle de bains est
certainement d'une importance
considérable qu'il s'agisse aussi bien
de la ville que de la campagne comment
se fait-il que certaines installations
modernes ne paraissent pas donné entière
satisfaction aux usagers vous posez là
une question difficile et délicate à
comprendre pour beaucoup sitôt après la
guerre les besoins satisfaire était
considérable et il fallait doter le plus
rapidement possible des personnes qui
étaient absolument sans logement d'un
toit à peu près convenable cela a
empêché d'utiliser les moyens
nécessaires pour pouvoir installer des
salles de bains véritablement
confortable alors peut-on dire que la
salle de bain pour chaque est pour
demain demain 7 un mot qui n'est pas
très précis mais certainement il faut
croire et on peut être certain que tous
les français posséderont un jour une
salle de bain parce que c'est un élément
d'une telle importance dans la vie
quotidienne que puisque les français ont
été capables d'avoir peut-être trop tôt
l'automobile pour chacun et bien un jour
ils seront de la même manière la salle
de bain pour chacun
[Musique]